hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the evil within another
triple a horror game much like alien
isolation that came out during Halloween
time with the intent to scare the pants
off of me
and I'm very much ready to roll now that
may seem like a high brightness but
actually I cannot even see the middle
thing in there so I'm gonna go forward
with oh hello well then for the weak and
fearful well that sounds like me but I'm
gonna go standard difficulty for now
just to see what I can get myself into
now I don't know how much that Mouse is
gonna be in there if you can even see it
but I'm using a gamepad for this one
because I heard that it was better
designed to be used with this instead of
a mouse and keyboard so I'm gonna give
it a try okay 104 copy code 3 eta three
minutes
that's pretty cards I know you're just
coming off the case but I'm afraid we're
to have to make a detour that's alright
sounds serious is it a riot is that me
calling out just before I picked you up
said it was multiple homicides half a
dozen units already on scene yeah maybe
it's the ghost of that doctor who went
schizo and chopped up all those patients
Oh what happened
some patients disappeared some kind of
scandal yeah still
gives you the creeps then then no not
really Joseph you think there's a
connection no not at all it's a
possibility
I believe the records were sealed
dispatch this is detective Castellanos
in 184 what's the situation
Oh wolves rumbling oh my goodness that's
another reason why I wanted to use it
because of Rumble do it say on the road
you jackass oh this is gonna be fun what
I heard about this game I really got
outlast vibes from it because it seemed
to take place in a hospital setting and
obviously the intro no any thoughts
oh thank you very much you're very
helpful so like I said this is made by
the developers of the original Resident
Evil series early said least the main
developer guys from that series but he
made this with the intent of really
making a visceral gritty horror
experience which is something that I'm
looking forward to cuz I mean outlast
was like a hidden gem it was out of the
indie scene but it came from developers
who had experience in the genre contact
dispatch and let them know what's
happening
Joseph Kidman you're with me we're gonna
have a look around god boss I gotta
admit it looks pretty but that might
just be a pre-rendered cutscenes but
here we are in the game let's go into
the abandoned hospital and for once I'm
not alone which is an interesting thing
chapter one an emergency call oh come
along my police amigos yeah this is
probably why it was better with the
gamepad than mouse and keyboard because
it's gonna be third-person perspective
throughout the entire game as far as I
know now whether or not all these police
cars are empty for a reason I'm gonna
assume that some psycho guy up in there
is already murdering all of my brethren
so this is gonna be fun charge right in
da my me ding-dong anybody home Oh
smells like blood oh yeah
stay sharp okay
I like this guy I'd like the best look
on him what kind of energy looks like me
don't let anyone else through this door
I can be an extra set of eyes we don't
know what's happening here
you're a backup good call let the girl
stay in the back she obviously can't
help at all
anyway this is not good
most assertedly bad what happened to
here whoa hello did you hear something
yes I did the banging and clattering do
you mean you didn't okay how do I run
alright he's just gonna scatter oh hi
there okay good to know
you were just intentionally pacing me so
that guy would come slouching down on me
who's there oh that's totally out are
you injured what happened here did you
do this yeah it might impossible move
Vic I've got it the security cameras
might tell us something they might
indeed I'll go check it out and then
venture off on my own so that I can be
kidnapped by the way I'm a handsome son
of a [ __ ] there's some kind of
stereotype here being a detective and a
handsome murder case oh yeah that'll
work whatever you're shooting at I'm
sure it's gonna die whoa okay it's the
hidden up in this [ __ ] hello
oh it's Alastair okay bye
that's totally the head I knew is gonna
be the hidden well this is gonna turn
out fun for me I'm just an innocent
detective oh no [ __ ] we're right into it
oh holy crap hello this is the scene
from the demo that a lot of people saw
he'll love us aroud please don't drink
my blood it's probably not good for you
given that I'm a stereotype detective
it's probably filled with alcohol and
cocaine all right come on come on man
you're gonna get eaten alive oh hi
are you the guy that's gonna eat me
alive you're pretty oh well at least
this game got right into the thick of it
is that body just jiggling dead or is it
actually someone no that's that's a dead
body oh okay oh come on come on now what
are you doing what are you doing over
there oh that's okay I can't exactly see
what you're doing I can only hope that
it's good the sound is splattering wet
stuff hitting the ground you're cooking
spaghetti I don't know oh you're not
cooking spaghetti are you is that tomato
sons
okay it's weird because the bodies here
just slightly wriggling and that guy on
the left looks like something I've seen
before oh okay I got it I know what I'm
doing here oh I'm gonna grab it or
something I don't know I want that knife
come on
almost got it oh boy the music is still
relaxing come on come on I'm gonna stab
this guy or I'm not gonna step I'm gonna
pull it out of him the reverse stabby
I'm not you feel used to that okay oh
all right
well then he took my trench coat the
douche this guy's gonna pay all right
now we're actually into the game I
actually really excited to play this
like I haven't had a chance to play many
of these games and then alien isolation
comes out how do I I know there's a way
to crouch I don't want to do there we go
okay
okay all right then I'll just stand
straight up excuse me sir would you
please
oh yes caress my hand her head with your
head so is there like a cover mechanic
in this game
I've never played any before I tried to
play a sample of it at a PAX Prime but
they wouldn't let me play like it was
like oh come on man I just want to track
it up a little bit hey I haven't YouTube
channel in 1:9 it's like nope now I
ain't gonna work
alright so I'm grabbing these keys I'm
guessing don't mind me
oh I want to get out of here I want to
get out here let's go back dude dude
first death first death of the game oh
oh good is that my dead body please yes
okay so obviously I was supposed to get
the keys but I was supposed to do
something else to hide or I didn't get
them expeditiously enough so that I
could get back I'm not sure exactly what
I did wrong there come on stop hitting
him he's eviscerated enough then I
follow right behind he'll never know I'm
like a shadow in the night oh my me
you'll never know oh I'm so stealthy if
you could just not spend ten seconds
putting it in your pocket
we'd be able to get out here I'm
assuming that I need to follow me
I'm glad the physics system is working
in this game yep take your time no rush
at all no not in a hurry okay
squeak as much as possible yeah that
breathing's not worried some you know
horror games gonna be good when it's got
all the sounds ready to go I'm glad
because this guy was so talkative in the
beginning now he's gonna being nice and
quiet not even talking to himself hello
say you I like how the camera system
work that's actually a benefit to it
because most of these things especially
when the old resident evil' people know
that the control scheme was not very
good very stick figure is when you walk
run run oh hey run faster I can see him
I know this is specifically designed to
be the dull look back looking back is
bad
wait what
why oh why the slip-and-slide of death
build this place one of these hospitals
all always got to be filled with
nightmares I know it's in my mouth live
all right moving on up to the east side
let's get the hell out of here
let's go meet my clone of markiplier
outside I wonder if he's okay probably
not if I got stabbed by the douche when
he was right behind me maybe he was the
guy maybe they're all in on it
maybe the extra set of eyes from the
lady would have been great help why not
that guy was fast
zip-a-dee-doo-dah fast this is a nice
dance you're doing maybe we could be
serious about our escape for two seconds
I know I know I know your leg hurts I
know suck it up and stop being a baby am
I even going the right way I am NOT am i
so something over that I need some
secret that might tell me that I'm not
an idiot and went the wrong way
okay no I wanted to go this way the
whole time don't mind me totally know
what I'm doing as with most of these
organs I'm trying my best to figure out
how to
well alright then there's an angry sewer
monster somewhere around here
what about sir is this amnesia all over
again
was that it has to be a water never mind
climbing up anyway I have no idea what
I'm saying totally forgot so I'm just
gonna keep rambling on until I circle
back to what I was talking about I have
no idea Oh with most of these horror
games that I play
oh hello who are you I usually don't
know exactly what I'm doing but I have a
good inclination of horror instincts to
know when things are bad alien is
isolation through me because it made me
go really slow but for this one I want
to make sure is the exit are you asking
him are you asking me I don't know
where's the engine where are the other
drugs going all no from sewer beside the
locked gate at the far end of the sewer
there's a ladder which would take you to
the old ward if you could make it
through there you would find an elevator
leading outside you would be the one who
escaped you might be the one who
survived thanks buddy
ah you're so friendly Oh we'll catch up
another time never so have a good one
god I gotta admit it's really pretty a
lot of people were worried when they saw
previously this game then again this is
on PC so the graphics are basically
unlimited up to how the game engine is
but I gotta admit this is really pretty
and from playing so many of these you
know Unity engine horror games and they
may have been good in gameplay but in
graphics they severely lacked to see
something actually triple a quality game
come out of a studio and know it's like
all about the horror oh I love it so I
must thoroughly try to enjoy this to the
best of my ability and I'm climbing a
long ladder that doesn't feel good oh
good I'm still in the hospital just did
a secret dungeon a part of the hospital
you know every hospital has it all right
maybe I could just camp out in this jail
cell and I wouldn't have to worry about
anything anymore no no stem system
operation test begins success
confirmation of brainwave
synchronization losses minimal
continuing experiment agent collects the
data anomaly occurs not with the subject
the sonographer claim they weren't
feeling well and then fell into a coma
for reasons unknown doctor orders the
stem system terminated
to applicants complaining of nausea and
falling unconscious one after another
those who can still move plan their
escape from the hospital but for unknown
reasons are unable to though the stem
system should have been deactivated
subjects maintain brainwave
synchronization with the hosts oh good
is it the wall Rider is it Billy Billy
Bobby hope Billy hope I agree on what
his name is Billy hope I believe hmm Oh
hammer does that mean that it's saved
over on the right I have no idea
also I got a mitt it's really weird cuz
his whole game is like in two three five
widescreen give us it a very cinematic
look although my floating head in the
corner may look a little odd placed in
here but I like it nonetheless I mean
the film Graham added kind of gives it
that movie style feel and I'm still
probably bleeding profusely out of my
leg was that pp that is dripping from
the ceiling distinctly yellow whoa oh
that's not good look at that that's bad
Oh God hide oh yeah he doesn't know come
on come on yeah he totally did not see
where I went no way he's gonna come in
here was I supposed to like block off
that oh god this bad the heartbeat is
started was that necessary was unlocked
oh yeah I speak his language whoa whoa
temper dude you're the one who decided
to play with your food you lock me in
that weird carnival of Horrors
okay thank you not gonna leave killing
till he can't hear is breathing but he's
being very angry somewhere else did not
realize I was still running away from
this dude it's the music is he coming
back oh god is this one of those he
doesn't go away situations early don't
like that ow
oh god he's coming back Oh Oh God
don't don't dude don't make me look bad
okay so he's just patrolling around here
oh god this is not gonna end well for me
yeah yeah I'm totally in there yeah rage
rage against the machine reigns the
person who put you in that face cage
yeah just me and her over that way
totally calmly yeah yeah well how's
about some moves yeah yeah okay I just
kind of wait till he turns back the
other way I didn't know that was loud
dude calm down bro I know I get it whoa
whoa whoa hey you didn't see nothing
yeah I know get it you've no need to
talk to yourself you're not crazy just
yet Oh
whoa whoa this is my guess
do I go back in there yeah what do I do
[Music]
okay whoa
flipping through the wood I didn't know
which way he was gonna go I didn't know
he's gonna waltz out the door oh good
lordy
that's mannequin too sick sorry I'm bad
at this I'm gonna get better at it I
know
don't go in there stop hiding the closet
come out of the closet oh yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah this time no screwing around
this time do it for real
all right come on come on oh damn it I
missed my opportunity turn around turn
around you big weirdo look up this way
no no no no no no no no oke stop he
ain't coming out these are just and
weirdly in the doorway yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah all cool bro it's
all good it's all good I know okay is he
gonna come out that door
what's he doing
god this camera angle I praised it a
little bit ago but I'm already like oh I
don't like it as much
[Music]
okay he's coming out so I'm gonna go
this way now okay cool I'm out I'm out
baby I'm out I'm out I'm out of you baby
there's a hiding space but I don't know
why oh god damn it you gotta be kidding
me
I gotta go in there what a dick bag oh
what the hell why is he in there I'm not
in there what a [ __ ] Oh what am I
supposed to do I am bleeding profusely
exactly everywhere Oh Oh God why
no no no no no no no no no no no no that
is the dick EEOC's done yet
wait is it so hard don't come back again
dude Oh got it
Oh God about
over there cutting uh yeah yeah I'm over
there yeah don't worry about me over
here ah the real means over there was
there the whole time
wanna tear whoa
good golly I better be out of here that
was actually really challenging not
gonna lie and stressful as hell come on
come on come on let's get out close it
good good good good good work good work
buddy good work pal check popping get
away from that psycho creepy guy okay
that's just as bad
ominous ominous thing over there come on
come on come on get to nail there
it opens for me oh this totally normal
forget you we're done
he's gotta be a chainsaw so he's gotta
be a psycho with a chainsaw can't be
someone normal yeah you're fine buddy
totally out of the woods you've lost
almost all of your blood you're fine
the guy just had to maim me where'd you
get blood in your mouth go through your
leg up to your mouth really you try for
a cigarette you are the worst stereotype
I've ever seen of a detective
[Music]
it just turns itself
and
[Music]
yay I'm so excited oh god I'm so excited
dad if that was just the intro sequence
I can't wait for the rest of the game
this is gonna be so cool how's it like
doing that brah
yeah cinch it off with a pack of
cigarettes and you're good to go all
right well that person's dead this is
where oh this is okay it's old building
coming down why was there a giant
explosion oh now I'm in a hurry
flip through some sings I'm out of here
baby
totally free what
okay
oh come on don't drive off without me
that's traumatic what the hell there's
Alistair there hey assassins crew
who the hell are you hey where's Joseph
yeah I'm sorry but you never came out I
waited but
go back
oh man did Michael Bay director
that's not
voila see how do you have even know
knows that he just kind of glanced
casually up I was like then I won't
question action movie stuff
so since we're in it all that that's not
normal
oh that's what's happening what's gonna
happen to California
forget the conservation of momentum man
that's weird
okay all right then I'm not gonna ask
any questions all right there's some
good devastation here I'm guessing I'm
just guessing the name of the game is
evil within there was that document
talking about how patients were going a
little loopy felling into comas and the
stem system was supposed to be the
activated ring everyone must be dead
of course everyone just a few bumps
we're fine
I guess covered in blood is totally
funny once we're far away a little
further and we'll be fine
the stem system
[Applause]
Oh beautiful well that was dramatic holy
Hannah oh it's awesome
totally illogical but awesome oh hello
chapter one
yes I'll save the game have you not been
saving my game this far yeah I'll take
that
oh okay good enough for me yay next
chapter I didn't expect it to be so
loopy insane going out of there but
that's my assumption the game is called
evil within it's all about in the brain
whoa hi there who the hell are you oh
this is the real me huh
where's this after I got out of the
ambulance I'm I guess this is the real
me and then I'm gonna wake up you gonna
tempt you just gonna believe me where
nurse
okay whoa what was that well no no I saw
something hello hi you're pretty you're
handsome do compliments not do it for
you you're just gonna okay you did
alright then I'll I'll be here
I'll be right here passing out this is
that stem thing that I've heard so much
about
oh oh oh god this is so messed up
awesome what's watching me through the
cameras this is me playing okay so I
gotta end this episode here I don't have
enough time to go on I have to get up
early tomorrow but either way this is
awesome I cannot wait to continue
playing this game absolutely amazing
let me know what you think of this game
in the comments below if there's
anything that I'm missing out on once
again
please let me know down below but do not
put spoilers down there just in case
people are reading obviously I will be
reading but then again I'll be playing
this big chunk so I'll be ahead of the
curve but just let me know what you
think of this game in the comments below
let me know if it's a disappointment to
you if it's good go to bed let me know
either way thank you all so much for
watching and you can check out outlast
in the annotations below and compared to
this or in the description below and as
always I will see you in the next video
the entrails of the Fallen on their face
[Music]
come back here I got some question for
you
[Music]